other news tonight president donald  trump held a press briefing today where  he continued his attacks  on the mail-in voting system he also  criticized nevada for passing  legislation that ensures every  registered voter  receives a mail-in ballot for the  general election  take the state of nevada take that  little  scam that's going on over there with the  clubhouse politician governor  take that where the votes don't even  have to be in  till seven they get counted seven days  after november third  that means if nevada is a very important  state i think we have a great chance of  winning that state  if the votes don't have to be in 4-7 and  they're not counting the votes  seven days later that means how are they  going to predict a winner on november  3rd  earlier this month the trump campaign  filed a lawsuit against nevada's  secretary of state barbara  zvezi the lawsuit alleges that many of  assembly bill's four's provisions will  essentially  undermine the election's integrity